last week's dramatic events have brought
back memories gelatine Jean remembers
the military coup of 1980 very well he
was a student in Istanbul at the time to
this day he is haunted by the brutality
he experienced this is where they
arrested I was wedged between two cars
the police jumped out put a sack over me
to the police station there the
so-called interrogation began they beat
the soles of my feet administered
electric shocks he pried from me asleep
and shouted abuse at me for two days
some 650,000 people were arrested in the
course of a few days
they included left-wing activists like
Jang liberal thinkers and many Kurds the
push took place on September 12th 1980
falling a period of unrest between left
and right-wing groups martial law was
declared he stumbles Taksim Square
became a symbol of the coup last week
this square was once again occupied by
soldiers determined to overthrow the
government and seize power days later
people stopped to take photos here
thousands of AKP supporters answered air
to ones call to take to the streets to
defeat the coup our government and our
president we're strong together our
lives will now go on as normal
we're coming out of this stronger we
won't let anyone bring us down Elton
John is glad the coup was a failure but
he doesn't share the joy of a Diwan
supporters either he says this time it's
a battle between two authoritarian
forces in his view that wasn't the case
before 36 years ago the coup was not
against the government
but against a large portion of society
against those who were fighting for an
emancipated and democratic future
regardless of whether these people were
students or businesspeople the army
wanted to stop this development grief
and defiance as the civilian victims of
the attempted coup are laid to rest
Allah is great mourners cry some accuse
religious authorities of using the
funerals as an opportunity to display
their might in the cities AKP supporters
have been patrolling the streets at
night soldiers should never again use
their weapons against their own people
even if they couldn't be held
accountable they will never escape
punishment from Allah critics of the
government fear the failed coup could
cause Islamist forces to rally around
erawan further strengthening his grip on
power the attempted coup will make it
easier for Iran to impose his vision of
an authoritarian autocratic system
almost as bad for democracy as a
military coup for years Jon has been
fighting for the generals involved in
the 1980 coup to face justice as well as
the authorities who tortured him but to
no avail
still for John a military coup is never
the answer
whatever side you're on a military coup
is never a good thing
no matter what it's against in the end
it's always the progressive forces and
the Kurds who paid a price to this day
gelatine John continues to fight for his
beliefs opposing autocratic forces and
the military he spent 19 years in prison
following the push of 1980 but he
believes a military coup can never be
the answer not even in Turkey